[Musique]
info intox c'est avec vous antoine fono
bonjour bonjour à faire et ce soir deux
fausses infos pro ukrainienne la
première elle concerne vladimir poutine
absolument rafale et la sécurité même du
président russe vous allez le voir en
croire ces publications twitter que vous
allez apercevoir la dîmière poutine
serait inquiet raphaël il peut la preuve
il porterait vous le voyez autour du
rouge un gilet pare-balles sais vous
allez nous dire qu'il a pris un peu
d'embonpoint il a même été d'abord là il
dit je voulais ce maître de vos propos
en tout cas oui effectivement un gilet
pare-balles aux minima c'est ce que en
tout cas sans me suggérer ce compte
twitter qui relaie régulièrement du
contenu pro uc régnait il y regarder
maintenant vladimir poutine commencent à
porter un gilet pare-balles et
sous-entendu commence à avoir peur il
faut dire que locataire du kremlin est
très à cheval sur sa sécurité à nos
confrères du midi libre à leur appel
goûteur de plats services de sécurité
aps les prêteurs pléthorique garde
rapprochée bunker antinucléaire il faut
dire que depuis le début du conflit le
président russe a fait l'objet de
nombreuses menaces les services de
renseignement ukrainiens d'ailleurs en
ce convaincu c'est cet article nous
l'apprend qu'il aurait d'ailleurs fait
l'objet selon eux d'une tentative
d'assassinât il y a quelques jours
c'était dans la région du caucase et oui
à ça circule d'ailleurs beaucoup sur
internet alors voilà pour le contexte là
notre photo à leurs gilets pare balles
ou pas alors tout d'abord il faut
retrouver la source deux images comme
d'habitude on procède à une recherche
d'image inversé on découvre plusieurs
atik illustré avec cette photo plusieurs
choses d'abord cette photo est ancienne
elle date vous voyez du 4 août 2017
c'est ce qu'on voit ici le président hu
c'est à l'époque et bien il lâchait des
poissons vous le voyez ici dans un accès
la photo qu'on voit en anciens qui n'a
pas été recadrée l'article est bien nous
explique que le président s'était à
l'époque rendu dans la réserve naturelle
du lac baïkal et baïkal et qu'il avait
donc relâché on voit des alevins dans le
lac ce média en ligne russe vous allez
l'apercevoir lui met en avant cette
visite de vladimir poutine accès à
l'époque donc sur la préservation de
l'environnement au sein de ce lac baïkal
alors est ce que le président je portais
une protection balistique sur une vidéo
de ce déplacement que je vais vous
montrer immédiatement on voit plusieurs
voix à plusieurs moments et bien
effectivement renflement sur sur sa
veste en tout cas c'est ce que moi j'ai
pu constater faites moi confiance nous
avons acte est ici raphaël à la
rédaction deux experts
deux experts militaires nous l'avons
donc montrer ses différents clichés du
président russe ils sont pas en mesure
de nous confirmer que le chef de l'état
porte un gilet pare-balles en revanche
qu'ils peuvent nous dire il affirme que
c'est possible des gilets très fin
allant jusqu'à la classification vous
allez le voir 3a permettent en effet de
d'être équipé sous une nouvelle lumière
très fine à peine 1 quasiment invisible
et d'arrêter des munitions de quasiment
7 de calibre 7,62 c'est quasiment du
calibre de guerre une protection aussi
contre les coups de couteau sur le plus
probable en revanche est bien c'est un
problème médical raphaël car peu avant
cet événement quelques quelques semaines
avant le président russe avait fait une
chute lors d'un match de hockey sur
glace rappelez-vous qu'il a l'habitude
de se mettre en scène à travers des
événements sportifs certains médias
d'investigation russe nous nous disent
qu'ils auraient ainsi consulté plusieurs
spécialistes orthopédique à noter enfin
que depuis cet événement se lâcher la
main vladimir poutine n'a plus fait
d'apparition publique pendant huit jours
alors la photo elle vous l'aurez compris
lé c'est un vieux cliché sortie de son
contexte par des cons preuve craignent
un pour mettre en doute l'état de santé
de venir petit d'aucun autre fausse info
pro ukrainienne on voulait nous parler
elle concerne des autodafés supposé de
livres ukrainien oui absolument un fox
relayée par des hautes personnalités
c'est peut-être un peu inquiétant c'est
le cas de carl bildt c'est l'ex premier
ministre de suède sur twitter il a filmé
avec cette photo que dans des zones
occupées par l'armée russe donc il y a
des photos qui prouvent que les
occupants brûlent les livres d'histoire
ukrainienne avec un but effacés la
nation ukrainienne a ici info ou intox
et on a simplement entrer livres brûlés
ukraine sur internet et on retrouve
autre chose ce reportage d'une chaîne
ukrainienne d'information ils datent de
2000 d'ici et on trouve à 20 secondes
vous allez le voir un petit peu plus
loin voilà ici ses livres ce sont
exactement les mêmes que l'on retrouve
ici en bas à droite de notre précédente
photo ce reportage pour la petite
histoire il présente des manifestations
organisées en crimée à l'époque par deux
organisations politiques pro russes
elles avaient alors brûlé ce que vous
voyez des livres d'histoire ukrainien de
l'histoire moderne de l'ukraine des
manifestants qui soutenait à l'époque la
nomination du ministre de l'éducation
trop riche de l'époque de viktor
ianoukovitch
à noter également que des contre
manifestations avaient également eu lieu
dans l'ouest du pays quelques jours plus
tard pour dénoncer cette mobilisation et
pour défendre cette fois la culture
ukrainienne des fautes on l'a compris
mais est-ce qu'il ya eu des livres
ukrainien brûlé dans ce conflit et oui
c'est toute la question et c'est en tout
cas ce qu'affirme l'armée ukrainienne
sur son compte facebook dans cette
publication et elle affirme que des
agissements de ce type aurait lieu dans
les zones occupées à louang donniez
tchernihiv est soumis cependant nous
n'avons pu retrouver absolument aucune
photo mh prouvost ces destructions en
revanche que l'on peut dire c'est que
l'armée russe elle est là bien détruit
des bibliothèques c'est le cas ici de ce
reportage que vous pouvez apercevoir ça
a été le cas c'est le cas ici notamment
à tchernihiv en conclusion rafael vous
l'avez compris les infos qu'ils sont
aussi côté ukrainien elles peuvent même
surprendre un mousse un premier ministre
merci antoine fenaux info intox avec
antoine rester avec nous on se retrouve
dans moins de cinq minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans paris direct
[Musique]